[Music]
first things first I'm Francis I'm the
lead program manager for Chromebook
adoption at Google and so today we're
gonna talk all things Chromebook and I'm
joined by Russ white we'll talk about
grab-and-go today if you've been using
the Dory app great if you haven't used
it yet give it a download that's how
we'll take questions for this session so
go ahead and get that started post them
there we have a whole panel of people
here to answer your questions about
Chromebook deployments so please go
ahead and get that queued up so that you
can put all your burning questions there
what we're gonna talk about today is why
Chromebooks I think most of you are here
because you know but I'm just gonna make
sure we're aligned on that we'll talk
about driving adoption in your
organization I'm gonna tell you all the
secrets on how we did it at Google and
then of course Russ is going to talk
about grab-and-go so the first thing I
want to do is just share with you that
Google actually is solving a lot of the
same problems that most of our IT
customers are solving we're a mixed
fleet ecosystem of Mac Windows Linux and
Chromebook devices we have a huge
Chromebook fleet and as you can imagine
we're one of chrome enterprises largest
customers and we also care about
improving operational efficiency and
reducing IT spend and so that's one of
the reasons in a long list of reasons
why we love Chromebooks so from a user
standpoint Chromebooks offer a sort of
distraction-free productivity
environment that's purpose-built for
cloud workflows and obviously from a
business standpoint their security built
in by design an intelligent investment
both in management and cost and so
because of that sort of whole slew of
reasons Chromebooks are a great choice
for our organization and hopefully yours
and so with all of that in mind Google
set out with this goal that users are
happy and productive on Chromebook
devices and that's a very specifically
worded goal we could have set a goal
that said users use Chromebooks and that
just means we give Chromebooks to
everybody but we have this sort of
secondary
achievement of making sure that people
are happy it can do their jobs and can
do them well and are excited about being
on the platform and so if you share
those goals then this session I think is
going to be particularly interesting for
you so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to walk you through what we call this
adoption timeline which is kind of from
start to finish from evaluating
Chromebooks as a potential device to put
into your fleet all the way to getting
users up and running on that device
and how to handle sort of changes
including attrition from the platform
and what you'll see at the end is we're
going to provide some artifacts for each
stage of this journey so that wherever
you are in this timeline we've offered
something that will help you either in
the challenges of that space or maybe
even move on further down the timeline
then then you're in now so from the from
the onset you're probably going to be
evaluating what types of hardware are
sufficient or acceptable for your
environment and one of the questions
that we get asked actually quite a lot
is how do you decide what platforms to
bring in to the Google space what makes
Chromebooks great how do you determine
what are the qualities of a trusted
platform and what are the ways that you
look at security and management and so
there's an artifact if you haven't seen
it that we recently published that talks
about exactly what Google expects from a
platform when they bring it into the
fleet including prevention in terms of
risk of infiltration into the platform
risk detection the ability to manage the
device how much control we have over
what kind of data consumes all of those
features are listed in this document and
again at the end I'm gonna give you this
list of artifacts that you can reference
but when we evaluate all of our
platforms those are the things that we
consider and Chrome certainly passes the
test especially with the way that the
security is designed in the platform and
so if you're sort of on board with
bringing Chromebooks into your
environment the second most common
question we get is which Chromebooks
should we bring in there are of course
Google made hardware and we're really
excited about it and we think it's great
but we also including at Google support
third-party vendor hardware so there's a
lot of different choices and when you're
looking at what's the best device to
bring it and of course the first thing
that you're gonna think about our
performance and specs and what types of
work that people are doing but when we
surveyed Googlers as
bringing Chromebooks into the ecosystem
of choice the things that were most
important to them and these are in order
are they wanted a lightweight device so
our workforce is generally quite mobile
a lot of people move between offices
they do quite a lot of traveling we
exist in cities where there's a lot of
heavy commuting and so people are
carrying their laptops a lot and so
weight was one of the biggest
requirements the pixel book is the
lightest device in the fleet that we
offer and so it was obviously very
satisfactory to the users who adopted it
they also want a high quality Hardware
look and feel people who are doing
important work want to feel like the
hardware that they have supports that
important work especially when you have
a choice between other premium Hardware
options they want a device that's
supported by their peers there is the
sort of phenomenon if you choose a
Chromebook and you're really excited
about it and you enter a team where no
one else is using that device that it
can cause people to take sort of a
second look at their decision and really
question if that was a good choice and
so having peers understand what the
device is capable of and making sure
that it's sort of pervasive across roles
it's really important they want a great
battery life of course and a touchscreen
was actually close to the top four top
four reasons that we got from Googlers
and so achieving all of these things was
actually quite simple for us with pixel
book because it is high performance it
is a high quality piece of hardware it
has a touchscreen and it can work in
tablet mode and it's the lightest device
in the fleet it's so because of that the
employees that we survey 90 percent of
them are quite satisfied and want to
keep and would recommend their pixel
book to another team member and so once
you've selected the kind of devices that
you're gonna bring in your environment
now the next question is more strategic
are we going to mandate from a business
standpoint that users will now adopt
Chromebooks that's our new fleet or is
there going to be an ecosystem of choice
where people can choose and you need to
influence their behavior and so at
Google we actually do have both
scenarios and different teams for
different reasons and so each of those
different approaches require different
strategic ways of executing on them
managing change and telling people that
their platform preference is not going
to be part of the story when they select
their device requires things like making
sure that you're choosing the right
people to start with and expanding your
scope
two better candidates and if you saw our
presentation last year and it's up on
the channel you can reference it if you
did it we talked a lot about
segmentation and how we think about
segmenting user types and identifying
good candidates for Chrome OS before we
sort of push the device in mass to
people who might not be prepared for it
and what you'll learn later in this
presentation is that the percentage of
people who don't have experience with
Chrome OS is actually a lot higher than
even we anticipated within Google and so
that means that if you're going to push
this change it requires a lot of care
and if you're working in an ecosystem
where people have a choice that's a
different story and so that's where we
do a lot of marketing initiatives what
we found is that getting the device in
the hands of the users is one of the
most effective ways to get them excited
about the device and so Russ is going to
talk later about grab-and-go which is
one of the key initiatives that help
users get experience with Chrome OS
before they sort of make the plunge or
or exposed to the change and so I call
this out because if you're going to
deploy Chromebooks you have to sort of
consider which of these if not both are
going to be true for you and then
consider that either change management
or a lot of Education and marketing is
going to be required depending on what
you do obviously from a provisioning
standpoint we're really excited that
chrome so easy to provision so in the
case of a Chromebook it's really a
matter of enterprise and rolling the
device and delivering it to the desk
because of the nature of the way that we
image alternative platforms like Mac and
Windows
we save a hundred and nine minutes every
time a Chromebook has deployed a place
of one of those other platforms and so
from a management and operation
standpoint the more Chromebooks we
deploy we have this sort of exponential
gain and that's just based on the nature
of images for those other platforms
within our ecosystem and so you've
provisioned a device which is great and
you've delivered it to the users desk
and this is where we actually learned
quite a lot and this whole presentation
is designed to try to prevent you from
having to learn all of the things that
we spent a long time figuring out and so
what we first tried to do was just
respect that people were new to the
platform and then give them as much
information as possible for them to be
successful
and the way that we sort of determine
its success at this point which is
getting up and running and sort of
keeping the Chromebook as your primary
device is do they stay on the platform
and so if users if we're experiencing
attrition from the platform that means
we're doing something wrong
and so what we learned is there's sort
of three basic phases that users are
going through when they're adopting this
new platform the first and foremost
thing on their mind especially with new
hires is I just want to get email
calendar and like the essential work
apps set up that's the first thing on
their mind so when we talk about
sophisticated like cool pro tips and
productivity hacks and workflow examples
it's way too much it actually underlines
that they're about to experience a
learning curve and so we don't present
that mountain on the first day that
somebody gets a Chromebook we sort of
ease them into the basic critical things
that they need the kind of second phase
after the first few days and once you
get into that first or second week is
personalization so people tend to
download personal apps they're starting
to translate their workflows from other
platforms and so that's sort of like
basic information of tips and tricks I
used to do this on Windows how do I do
it on Chrome or I'm more familiar with
Mac kind of curated information that
will help people ease into the
transition is what we present at that
time frame and then once you get a few
weeks further down the line that's when
we get into that productivity hacks
here's I use hotkeys and keyboard
shortcuts and those type of things and
so this is an important lesson for us
because eighty-four percent of the
Googlers that were assigned a Chromebook
device this year had little to zero use
of the platform and that's a lot that's
self-reported when we survey the new
people who were assigned this year and
so that really taught us a lot about the
type of information that we need to
provide and how we need to break it down
and so again the artifacts that we use
and the strategy will be given to you
guys at the end of this presentation so
including tips and tricks campaigns and
the type of content we have there and
also surveys so we do survey all new
users of Chrome OS and we asked them
about their initial impressions so that
we can give direction for additional
resources that they need but another
important part of running Chromebook
adoption is staying on top of sort of a
monitoring goal so if you set a target
for Chromebook adoption or you're just
trying to understand the basic health
when you introduce this in the
environment there's a massive monitoring
and dashboard need and we spent so many
iterations design
charts and figuring out what questions
to ask should this be a part chart
should this be overlaid on something
else and so we've done all of that work
and provided a sort of template example
for you on what a dashboard could look
like if you're trying to answer some of
these questions because these are the
five things that we generally wanted to
answer how many people have a Chromebook
versus how many people are using it as
their actual daily drivers so there is a
circumstance where an employee could
potentially have more than one device
and we treat that circumstance
differently so if they have a Chromebook
and also another platform that's not the
same definition of success as if a
Chromebook is their only operating
system and so that's question number one
for us in terms of defining adoption we
also want to know why people leave
Chrome OS and you could just ask them
and you'll get this massive flow of open
text that you have to later interpret
we've also done that for you so we've
given you sort of a list of reasons that
you can use to aggregate and collect
that data how many people are choosing
the laptop at the time that they have a
hardware decision so any milestone where
people could select an alternative
platform whether it's moving to a new
role or refreshing a device we want to
know what the trends are their new hire
assignment is absolutely critical
because it sort of sets the tone for
what the future will look like in terms
of growth if you're trying to kind of
create a new population of users versus
focusing on converting the current
population and then lastly where does
Chrome assignment stand against some of
the other platforms so our goal is that
Chrome assignments are above the other
platforms and obviously in this sort of
up into the right line so we've created
some examples on those questions and how
we track him monitor them so that you
can potentially take that back and so I
mentioned that we serve a new users but
we also survey this like super important
and very well-respected group at Google
which are people who leave the platform
and so they tell one of the most
important data parts of the story what
we found is that you could ask a user
hey if we gave you a Chromebook would
you be able to use it and you'll get a
lot of anecdotal and hypothetical
reasons why they could or could not but
actually asking someone to try it and
figuring out when they leave the
platform in their journey and why
they're leaving produces the most
valuable insights for us and so what we
learned is that 30% of the people who
left the platform left for reasons that
we could
in theory control and so reason category
is like education resources training
materials communication about what the
platform is and what it does and so
because of that that attrition data both
tells us how to set the direction to
sort of maintain retention but also
gives us the most actionable feedback
for product teams and we'll talk a
little bit about that right now so our
goal is obviously that people can use
the platform as much as possible but we
also have this responsibility to
communicate this story of if people
can't use it or don't want to let's
figure out why and make chrome
competitive against the other platforms
and so we encourage all of our customers
to sort of do the same filing a chrome
bug is sort of step one to collecting
feedback and Google does this as well
and then stack raking and prioritizing
your requests is the next phase and so
we presented a template for you in sort
of our kit that you'll get at the end of
the day and these might seem like
obvious questions but this helps sort of
narrow exactly what's required for you
to both collect and monitor your own
story but also creates an artifact that
like your Technical Account Manager or
customer success manager can help
navigate and escalate where necessary
and so this is driven by that attrition
feedback and also the new user feedback
creating those surveys in a way that's
easy to monitor and measure and present
up on a dashboard can be hard it
requires a lot of data aggregation and
we dedicated a huge amount of UX
research resources to this so that we
can present these artifacts in a way
that we think are intelligent and are
actually valid research methods so
you'll get those too and so just to sort
of summarize where we sit in terms of
Chromebook at Google
every time we deploy a Chromebook based
on the devices that we're purchasing we
save 50 percent just in device costs
every time we deploy a Chromebook over
another platform which I mentioned
before we save a hundred and nine
minutes and for every single Chrome OS
support interaction there are three from
another platform at Google and so that
means those other platforms are
generating three times as much support
and there's a lot of reasons for that
and we could talk about them but
obviously they have to do with
complexity of the platform and the way
the images work and a number of other
things that users can experience just
based on what the platform is capable of
and we do have approaching 90 thousand
active chrome devices at Google and I
mentioned before that ninety percent of
our users who have pixel books are
satisfied with the devices and would
recommend them to their employees and so
based on this sort of timeline and all
of the things that we've accomplished we
see this as great success we tripled our
adoption population since last year with
adoption being defined as users using
the platform as their primary device and
so this URL is available you guys can
also get access to this after the
session but what this URL points to is
the timeline that we spoke about and all
of the artifacts that are related to
each of those milestones so that
includes surveys tips and tricks'
campaigns the dashboard template example
and any other resources that we felt
like could be beneficial to you wherever
you are in the stage of your adoption
journey so definitely take a snapshot of
that so you can download it and have a
look and so I mentioned before that one
of the best ways to get users excited
about the platform is to get the device
in the hands of the user and grab-and-go
has been one of our most successful ways
to do that so Russ is here to talk about
that great thanks Francis I'm Russ let
me talk to a little bit about
grab-and-go our self-service Chromebook
loaner program that we run at Google
we're gonna talk a little bit about why
we created it while we're still working
on it how it works what it is and then
talk a little bit about some of the
successes that we've seen at Google and
perhaps how you can make some of those
your own we have some really great
options for how you might be able to
deploy your own grab-and-go program so
first up let's talk about why the Google
is just like any other company we lose a
lot of time to IT downtime our devices
break just like everyone else's and when
we first started this program we were
focused on minimizing that downtime so
IHS market estimates that North American
businesses lose over 700 billion dollars
a year just to IT downtime and we also
knew that the the traditional loaner
program journey really isn't great for
anybody so are you
had to come to help desk on the help
desk was open they had to wait in line
they had to get a loaner device that
probably wasn't a great device and they
had to do that again when they were
returning it for our IT staff they were
maintaining those devices ordering them
provisioning them and they also had to
spend all the time handing them out and
none of that is really fun work for our
team so we had a lot of signals telling
us go in this direction we also had a
couple of opportunities that we knew
about things like that the fact that
Google employees use our help desks at
least once per year on average and often
times quite quite a bit more than that
and we also knew that around 80 or 85
percent of Googlers could be fully
productive on Chrome OS not all of them
required a Windows or a Mac OS to be
productive so we knew that we could put
a device in their hands that they could
get their work done on and then why
we're continuing to work on this program
we're still iterating on it we're still
making it better around 35% of Googlers
used the grab-and-go program in 2018
around half of them 18% were using the
program to work around a true
productivity blocking problem so some IT
problem maybe their device was broken or
forgotten or something like that and
then the other half another 18% or so
we're using the program for more
convenience reasons they'd be picking up
a device between meetings or people are
traveling and just want to pick up a
laptop when they arrive something like
that
so at its simplest this is grab and go
you walk up to one of our shelves there
they're just out there you can use it
whenever you'd like you walk up pick up
a device sign in with your Google
account and get back to work when you're
done you bring it back to plug it in and
that's it there's no IT team
intervention required you don't have to
talk to anybody you just walk up and
take a laptop so the core components of
the program start with the kind of
physical domain so the devices are a key
key part of this we make sure that our
devices that we put in our program are
enterprise-grade we want Googlers to be
productive when they're using devices we
want them to be durable they need to
kind of survive going from person to
person being thrown back on the shelf
being thrown in your bag and we also
want it to be cost conscious we don't
want to spend so much money that we're
really giving everyone two devices we
want it to be perhaps a little bit
cheaper than that so that's the first
piece the second is
the shelves that we buy so we we prefer
to have shelves that are modular because
we have offices of different sizes
sometimes we need a little tiny one
sometimes we need a very big one in in
all of these cases we want charging to
be built in that's a key part of the
experience you need to be able to pick
up a device and walk away with it and
know that it's fully charged so that
needs to be an obvious feature of the
shelf and we also want them to have key
safety features and that's something
that we didn't think about a lot early
on but we really do a lot now we want
them to be resistant to tipping we want
them to be grounded we want them to be
coded at a non-conductive material so
that you can kind of remove that from
from your line of thinking and the last
piece is we we designed our signs and
stickers to be very self-explanatory we
found that the the loner flow that we
designed was a little bit awkward for
some users it felt like you were walking
up and stealing a laptop if it wasn't
explained at all so the signs that we
put up there are very clear very concise
there step signs that's actually very
similar to what you saw in the last sign
saying no just really pick it up sign in
and bring it back when you're done and
we also placed instructions at key
points in the user journey so when you
open the laptop there are stickers
inside the laptop that explain how to
sign in how to connect to Wi-Fi how to
return it things like that another key
ingredient of our program is Chrome OS
itself Chrome OS makes it very easy to
just sign in and get back to work so
things like chrome sync or the
integrations with G suite products make
it incredibly easy to get back to work
once you've signed in these devices are
very very secure because of the built-in
features of chrome OS things like
verified boot automatic updates signing
restriction those are all super easy to
configure we'll talk a little bit more
about that in the next couple slides and
these devices are very very easy to
maintain we manage our entire fleet just
with the click of a few buttons and the
admin API the admin panel so we have a
very easy time managing a fleet of you
know upwards of 2,000 devices so it's
not all just signs and devices in Chrome
OS there is actually quite a large
management infrastructure that we've
built at the center of all of it is an
app engine application that's kind of
the brain of the program
that application is where program
administrators monitor the the
performance of the program who's
assigned to what which shelves might be
low in stock those kinds of things and
it also streaming all of that data and
information to bigquery another key
piece of it is Google's admin API that's
where we enforce a lot of those policies
like verified boot one other key policy
that we enforced there is a custom-built
Chrome application is pushed to every
single grab-and-go device so when the
user signs in the first thing they see
is that application popping up and
greeting them and saying hey welcome to
grab-and-go here's how you use this
device that application also guides them
through setting and return dates they
can ask questions there they can report
problems those kinds of things and then
of course all of these things allow for
integration with the other internal
tools right so we have a ticketing
system we have an inventory management
system those kinds of things so like I
said when we first deployed grab-and-go
we were doing so for the you know avoid
lost productivity situation so forgotten
broken laptops but after we deployed it
we found that Googlers were using this
program for things that we didn't really
expect and we're still not exactly sure
how to measure the you know the benefit
of those things so some of those things
are travel so we found that a lot of
Googlers will actually leave their
laptop at home travel to another office
pick up a laptop there use that put it
back on the shelf and then travel back
home just to avoid carrying a laptop
with them we also have big groups of
shift workers inside of Google we
recently published a blog on how way Moe
is using grab-and-go so they have shift
workers testing driverless cars and they
take a grab-and-go device with them
every time they go out so there's a
couple shifts of those workers and
they've saved money on not needing to
buy devices for all of them and they
also have a really great management
solution with grab-and-go and then of
course like francis was saying it's a
really great way to get Chromebooks in
people's hands using the device is a
really great way to break down barriers
and understand the power and ease of use
of Chrome OS so we're very happy with
grab-and-go Google we found that
each loan really only needs to save
about 25 minutes of productivity time to
pay for itself and our most conservative
estimates show that in 2018 we saved
around 17 million dollars if you convert
productivity time to dollar so this is
definitely something we're gonna
continue investing in and it's something
that like I said we're very happy with
if you're thinking about to point your
own grab-and-go program but you're
seeing all of these pieces that need to
be put in place and thinking I will not
do that good news we have really great
partners that can work with you so we've
spent the last year so working with some
of Google's closest partners the list is
much longer than than just what you see
here the their services range from
anywhere from from you know procuring
Hardware setting up devices customizing
the application that we built doing
inventory management training of your
team on how to run the program
anything up to and including even White
Glove service if you're more of a DIY er
and you're thinking this looks great I
can do that
that's excellent we have code all open
sourced on github github calm slash
Google slash loaner everything's there
from code to art to deployment plans to
whatever everything you'd need to deploy
your own grab-and-go program and like I
said the partners talk to your partner
definitely start a conversation there or
feel free to engage with one of the ones
that we showed on the last slide all
right well thank you everyone for coming
and thank you again have a great day
[Applause]
[Music]